the jurogan experience were you aware of
how
twisted the system was before you
started doing this litigation before you
started going over the the peer-reviewed
papers and finding out where they did
were you aware of how the system was set
up it came in two stages so i was i
after i finished my residency in family
medicine i did a robert wood johnson
fellowship for two years and and that
was a wonderful uh training in
epidemiology and research design and
statistics so that that's where i got
these skills that i came back and drew
on but family medicine is very hard in
an academic environment the the purpose
of the fellowship was to train academics
in family medicine to increase the
prestige of family medicine which seems
like a good idea but family medicine is
very difficult in an academic
environment because they're
the family docs a low man on the totem
pole in the hospital and all the
specialists
specialists often don't treat them with
the respect they deserve and i decided
that my calling was to go be a doctor in
a
smallish town and i did that for 20
years but i had this robert johnson
fellowship training
always in the back of my mind and as we
got through the late 90s it became clear
that the drug companies were influencing
what was in the journals
and then the drug do you remember the
drug vioxx arthritis i have a friend who
had a stroke after taking vioxx yeah
so
it yeah i i got a letter from a mother
whose child
died 14 17 year old child died
from taking vioxx eight samples of vioxx
but
vioxx came along and there was an
article in new england journal
that murk had sponsored and it said it
was safe and was advantageous not
because it was any more effective but
because it reduced the risk of serious
gi problems
and then there was another article in
the new england journal of medicine
that fessed up to cardiovascular
problems
but the review article said
this may be due to the play a chance
because there were only 70 events
and such a small number of events
is
subject to statistical variation
and i knew
that
that was crazy because there were only
53 serious gi events which was the whole
reason for selling this 2 billion a year
drug was that it was safer on the gi
tract and there were only 53 events it
was an anti-inflammatory right it was
like yeah exactly so the idea was that
that was better than non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories exactly because it
because it didn't uh upset the stomach
the same way and this the science was
elegant and it might have worked but it
didn't um and in changing that balance
it made the blood more likely to form
clots
the physiology was a little more
complicated than just stomach or no
stomach and is
something like this the the issue is the
size of the trial because
you could have 10 people and none of
them could have a problem but you could
have 10 000 people and you could have
quite a few problems so you have to make
this the study as large as possible so
you get all this biological variation
between human beings where different
things affect different people in
different ways
that's part of it and you can have a
study of 8 000 people where you leave
out three heart attacks
and you flip the statistics and claim
that there's not a cardiovascular risk
okay so they just it was fraud it was
fraud
and you couldn't tell the fraud from the
article in the new england journal they
merck had submitted this data to the new
england journal and they did what peer
reviewers do which is not half the data
but make sure that the article makes
internal sense they published the
article and then this review article
came along
and they
gave a little bit more insight into the
cardiovascular problems but they blew it
off as the play a chance because there
are only 70 events
and that was crazy and at that point i
was sitting in my office at lunchtime
reading taking a break between sessions
reading this article
and i said that's it i got to find out i
got to figure this out there's something
so wrong going on here that it's beyond
my comprehension
so
an article was published in jama two
weeks later
that had a footnote that led to fda an
fda website that had
um enough data to see that merck had
been fraudulent about the heart attacks
and when i saw that i said i'm going to
leave practice and i'm going to figure
this out
and i worked for two years on a book
called overdosed america it was
published in 2004
and it had the vioxx story in it
and
uh a week after that book was published
vioxx was pulled from the market it
wasn't my doing
another study had mercs
merck had done a second study
that
showed the same thing that the risk of
strokes and heart attacks and blood
clots was doubled and at that point they
had to pull it because they were hiding
the data on this first study now the
second study came along and it was clear
that the jig was up for them and how
long had they been prescribing and
distributing vioxx at that point
uh it came out in may of 99
and that was september of 2004. wow
so 25
between 20 and 25 million americans had
taken vioxx and between 40 and 60 000
americans had died
died from the cardiovascular
consequences of vioxx as
in the same ballpark as the number of
americans who died in vietnam
died from taking this drug
that was no more effective at treating
arthritis or aches and pains
than non-steroidal anti-inflammatories
and caused forty to sixty thousand
deaths and what was the punishment for
merck
merck um there were 27 000 plaintiffs in
the litigation and they were awarded 4.7
billion
merck sold 12 billion dollars worth of
iocs in the four and a half years it was
on the market
so they
paid the plaintiffs 4.7 billion
and the department of justice fined them
a little bit under a billion dollars
but nobody went to jail well not only
that they're still making profit that's
a profit
they
murk excuse me um
vioxx
they probably made a small profit they
probably they took in 12 billion they
had research and development costs um
and marketing costs and all
manufacturing costs so a small profit of
what a billion dollars maybe they made a
billion in that wild
you can make a billion dollars from
lying joe it's even after being it's
crazy and the
merck's chief scientist saw the data
from that first study where the three
heart attacks were omitted and there's a
there's a uh an email that the wall
street journal published uh from march 9
2000 when they opened up the data on
that
and the email i'm paraphrasing but the
email said something like
it's a shame but the cardiovascular
effect is there
but
the drug will do well and we will do
well oh god
that's written down it's written and no
one goes to jail for that no i mean that
is insane i mean imagine any other thing
that you do that's fraud that causes
40 000 deaths between 40 and 60.
imagine any other thing any other thing
that you would sell imagine if that was
like oreo cookies or you know whatever
it's unheard of it's unheard of and
that's why it continues
because there's not adequate oversight
and there's no consequences
there's consequences but there's slaps
on the hand but yeah you know usually
when the fines are announced by the
department of justice the stock goes up
because the shareholders are happy to
have this burden off